hello oh my God they're speaking
[Music]
Dutch well it seems tears of the kingdom
is not the reboot or reimagining some of
us thought it was and today I thought
I'd give you my two cents on it so for
those who missed it in a recent
interview conducted by famitsu series
director hidemaro Fuji Bashi shared some
of his insights into the timeline
placement of breath of the wild and its
Sequel and honestly this came as a
pretty big surprise to me due to the way
tears of the kingdom was written I was
convinced that the Zelda team's
intention was to completely distance
themselves from the original timeline as
much as possible maybe even going as far
as rewriting history altogether it's
long been debated whether or not the
team actually wanted or cared about an
established timeline for the series to
begin with or if this was just done to
satisfy the fans those pesky nagging
fans like me personally I think it's a
little bit of both Nintendo isn't
exactly known to give into fan pressure
and feedback so if they really didn't
want to time timeline to exist they
would have insisted that these are all
disconnected stories you know like Final
Fantasy they would also not enable fans
further by publishing a book about it
not to mention it was mamoto and Tessa
who started suggesting a chronological
order for the games publicly back in the
9s but of course that was back then when
there were I think only five games total
CDI games not included of course
the nowadays we have more than 20 games
to work with and many prominent figures
from the early days like tzuka and
mamoto are no longer are part of the
Zelda Dev team if you were to ask me I
think Nintendo lost track of a
definitive order around the mid to late
2000s they did acknowledge the timeline
split brought forth by Arina of time and
even played into the idea of two
separate realities as Major's mask
followed up on the events of Link
traveling back to his childhood and Wind
Waker portrays the world he left behind
but I guess at some point they realized
they had all these other games laying
around which somehow had to be
retrofitted into the chronology as well
like the games made by Capcom and the
NES titles many of which didn't really
fit with everything else anymore and so
they came up with a Band-Aid solution
and that solution was the infamous third
timeline split which is essentially a
Dumping Ground for all the games that
didn't fit in with the rest and it
really shows it's mostly comprised of
older titles and to no one's surprise
it's by far the most inconsistent branch
of the timeline not that the rest of the
timeline is perfect by any means but you
know for the most part it works then of
course we got Skyward Sword which is a
prequel to well everything so this one
was an easy fit verely we have breath of
the wild a sequel to everything and the
idea of placing it so far in the future
that everything that came before is a
distant myth which barely has any impact
on current events was a pretty clever
way to start fresh it allowed for a
clean slate for the series without
messing up its Legacy but then tears of
the Kingdom made it complicated Again by
incorporating time travel and not just
any time travel but literally going back
to Hy rues founding technically shortly
after was founded now if you're someone
who's well versed in the Zelda Timeline
you know that hyro founding is something
that happened very early in the
chronology sometime after skyw sword and
before Minish Cap also Ganondorf wasn't
born yet during hyrule's founding it
would be eons before he came into the
picture in a of time so you can imagine
people surprised when raru introduced
himself as the first king of Hyrule and
I think this and some other moments in
the story that seem to mimic set pieces
from previous titles made a lot of
people lean more towards the idea that
this could indeed be a reimagining
particularly a reimagining of a of time
and two or lesser extent A Link to the
Past story given the whole you know
imprisoning War stuff and that all the
references to the older games are just
that references to give longtime fans of
the series a sense of familiarity which
is at least partially true either way
timeline or not and just to clarify I
would have been okay with it if it was a
reboot it's not my favorite solution but
I mean the original timeline is a bit of
a mess and I definitely don't see it as
something sacred that must never be
disregarded of course when it comes to
tears of the kingdom it was to be
expected that someone would have
eventually bring up the timeline
question at some point but I figured
they would either cleverly Dodge it with
some ambiguous statement refuse to
comment altogether or they would
straight up confirm that yes we're
starting over it's a reimagining of the
original timeline in a way but
surprisingly that's not what happened so
what exactly did Fuji bayashi have to
say about the timeline well he presents
the idea that even though we witness
Hyrule in its infancy it's possible that
it's not the same Kingdom seen in
previous titles the Old Kingdom of
Hyrule and its long history could have
been destroyed before raru EST Lish his
rule in this new land and most likely
even before the arrival of the zonai in
general which was actually already a
running Theory and it wouldn't be the
first time either since in the Wind
Waker Hyrule is also destroyed only for
a new kingdom to pop up in spirit tracks
called new Hyrule which is on a
different continent no less it is worth
pointing out that Fuji Bashi presents
this as a what if using phrases like is
it possible so it's not like he's
outright saying this is how it is but I
mean he is obviously trying to nudge Us
in the right direction here at least
that's the impression I get while it's
not an outright confirmation keep in
mind that this is how the Zelda team has
always approached the lore it's quite
rare to find definitive answers from
Nintendo when it comes to anything
regarding the Zelda Timeline it's always
phrased in a way that change remains a
possibility and nothing is absolute in
that sense the official timeline as a
whole is a suggestion a foundation fans
can use to build upon which I think has
always been a good setup when it comes
to grandom mythologies and fiction I
will choose ambiguity over cold heart
facts any day of the week it gives fans
who are invested in the lore something
to work with and at the same time ample
amount of room to do their own research
and interpret the lore in their own
unique way in fact when you think about
it if the Zelda Timeline was clearly
spelled out no gaps no inconsistencies
no room to fill in the missing pieces
then no one would ever even discuss the
timeline I mean what's the point if all
the facts are already laid out by the
developers it's exactly because the
timeline is an unsolved puzzle fueled by
Nintendo's ambiguity that people still
talk about it today as for the
statements made by Fuji Bashi I think
under the current circumstances this is
probably the most satisfying answer we
could have gotten I truly believe that
it suggests that the original timeline
is still relevant all these other
stories and events they still happened
midna might still be out there somewhere
we stopped an Angry Moon from crashing
into the Earth and tingle did end up in
jail like the criminal he is tears of
the Kingdom didn't change or rewrite
history nothing is lost breath of the
wild and its sequel reside in their own
little space at the very end of it all I
think it satisfies most people not all
of them of course you know you can't
please everyone but if you don't care
about timelines or even the story in
general great the games will no doubt
continue to follow the same trajectory
where you don't have to play any of the
previous titles to understand what's
going on in that sense most Zelda games
are already kind of a reboot or a soft
reboot I guess is a more appropriate
term meanwhile those who are invested in
the overarching lore and mythology can
continue to speculate and express their
creative thinking because despite Fuji
Bashi statements we are far from solving
all the Mysteries for starters if hyu
was utterly destroyed only to be
reestablished by raru far in the future
then which part of the timeline does it
follow up on the downfall child or adult
timeline a brand new reality or that the
existing realities converge at some
point and if so how and why also where
was the M sword in ru's time and what
became of the Triforce technically
there's only one timeline Branch where
the kingdom of hyu was destroyed and the
Massa sword and Triforce disappeared all
at the same time which would be the
adult timeline h Ru did fall into decay
in the downfall timeline but in Zelda 2
which is the last game in that reality
the kingdom and its monarchy are still
alive and kicking but then on the flip
side in breath and tears there's items
enemies and references present which
originate from all three realities which
of course hints more at the idea of some
kind of convergence these are all
unanswered questions and Mysteries we
can continue to investigate and at least
now we can do so without having to worry
about the possibility that it's all a
massive redcon and the old games don't
matter anymore I feel like that's the
most important thing here even if Fuji
Bashi statements are just him
improvising on the spot it doesn't take
away from the fact that he seems to
favor the idea that it fits in the
original timeline somehow if it was
meant to be a reboot he would have just
said so after all it's by far the
easiest answer to give also this might
just be me but I kind of like the idea
of Hyrule being this stubborn Kingdom
that just refuses to die no matter how
much it gets devastated it always
manages to rise from the ash once again
like a phoenix it's almost as if it has
to exist and the universe is like
correcting itself for something even in
real life civilizations rise and fall
but they never Disappear Completely even
when something new takes its place it
still inherits Traditions art language
and other aspects from that which came
before and so does Hyrule the kingdom we
see in Minish Cap or acarina of time are
far removed from later Renditions seen
in the Wind Waker Twilight Princess and
ultimately the era of the wild to a
point where it might as well be a
different place altogether but there
will always be things that survive
across the ages be it symbols names or
traditions either way I'm very excited
to see the theories and ideas people
come up with in the near future and if I
have my own you can bet that I'll be
making videos about it too but for now
that's all I have to say in case you're
wondering yes I'm still working on my
zonai shika connections video I'm
probably going to have to do some
rewrites or add certain parts because I
may or may not have made some
assumptions about the timeline of events
here and there which of course have now
become obsolete but I'm quite far into
production already so it shouldn't take
too much longer I hope I also have a few
shorts planned out to fill in the gaps
between videos I figured I might as well
join the trend and I have a pretty
special announcement regarding merch
coming up as well so plenty to look
forward to anyway thank you for
listening to my rambling and have a
great
[Music]
day